hi my name is mark carter i'm the
president of mc squared we're a
consulting
firm that helps companies with
uh technology access through technology
helping them develop new things and
working with companies
on quality systems both in the food
cannabis and pharmaceutical spaces
so today i'd like to talk to you about
uh an alphabet soup which is a quality
technical and statistical
statistical considerations for cannabis
testing
so normally i can start with this slide
because for me testing is a lot like
this
and many times we don't understand what
we're looking for or how we're going to
get to an answer or what we're going to
get so
it's kind of like rocky and bullwinkle
was the old thing of hey rocky watch me
pull a rabbit out of my hat
and and that's really kind of how you
end up developing great testing programs
and understanding exactly what you need
to do to be successful
with any type of product you put into
commerce
testing itself is built on and the
assurances of testing are built on
mathematics
and uncertainty so this is a quote
from w.a stewart who if you've done any
statistical
process control work you know that this
person
uh developed a short control chart but
he likes to say an element of chance
enters into every measurement hence
every set of measurements
is inherently a sample of certain more
or less unknown conditions
even in those few instances where we
believe that the objective reality being
measured
is a constant the measurements of this
constant are influenced by chance
or unknown causes and if we think about
testing as a whole
whether it be microbiological chemical
or physical testing
there really is a lot of uncertainty
that goes into understanding the answers
that we end up with and what we get
so let's just quickly talk about the
current cannabis climate
where federal legalization is
progressing slowly but we're seeing
state legal legalization continue to
progress
right the cannabis value chain for both
cannabis and hemp when i say that
uh is going to become more complex as
you move to value-added products
that's one of the things i'll mention
and go over a little bit more in this
in in the presentation the value chains
performance though can be characterized
by addressing consistent stages
for all product types right no matter
where the product is going to end up
we need to have a set of tests and
measurements that go along with that
to let us know that we're reliably
putting things into commerce
now testing can always generate an
in-depth knowledge
of the products as they move through the
supply chain
and the value chain right and your
greatest understanding
is created through measurement and
in-depth data analysis
at the end of the day what we're trying
to do is build a picture
of the products that we're selling from
both the safety
quality standpoint and then what does it
mean to the business as a whole
so what are some of the business
challenges we see with testing and this
again is a growing industry
you can look at other places where we
talk about
uh some analogous types of testing
that's been done some analogous type of
uh information that had to be learned
when we discuss
dietary supplements and other type of
botanical testing
many of the things that apply to a
cannabis that apply to cannabis have
applied to those markets first
but again you go back in and the
challenges for a lot of companies and
even at the grower level is how do i
administer a testing plan you know what
am i supposed to do
and then how do i communicate with
anybody a supplier who i'm either
getting product from or who i'm
or somebody i may supply to right what's
the cost of it all
we often talk about hey let's test test
test but you know again
it is a business and there are related
costs to that so
the next thing you want to look at is
okay is there value to the company and
the things that you're doing
many times with with the fact that
testing will be legislated along with
frequencies and stuff like that
you want to know exactly how it's going
to pay you back
the final point that i'd like to make on
business challenges and there's plenty
more but i think these are the ones that
are kind of consistent
with with the immediate needs of a
business is
again how how does the testing regimen
fit in with any regulation and then the
regulatory requirements for testing
themselves
one of the things i've i've often talked
about
is that the regulations in many
instances
are a guideline but they're also the
floor for what you're doing
you know again the cost of testing can
be can be valued looked at
and and measured but the biggest thing
is how do
how how does what i'm doing fit with
regulation
while also keeping an end user safe
and keeping the final customer satisfied
with the product that they're receiving
quality and safety both play into this
i use this as an example i found this uh
from the
you know bureau of cannabis control in
california
but i think what it does is it
highlights extremely well
you know the different categories of
product that we could be dealing with
with cannabis
and also the type of testing that can be
done
right so this was a phase-in plan and we
can see it goes back to 2019
but if you look at the testing that's
there you see a lot of testing that
deals with
uh you know different types of chemical
testing
we're talking you know mycotoxin testing
heavy metals testing you also have some
areas there
areas there for microbiological testing
and i think as you go across and look at
the products you see where those needs
are different
what i'm going to try to do in this talk
is just highlight
a balance between all of these and just
pick
certain areas where um you might want to
consider where microbiological testing
has different characteristics
and outputs then for instance your
chemical testing would
um i want to just discuss a little bit
the difference of okay when we're
talking about sampling what does it mean
when you talk about homogeneity and
non-homogeneity so
those are things that i think that are
important when you look at the way
testing is laid out
and you also consider that for the
product and again how it plays against
the regulations that you have that
you're trying to comply
with so just quickly
um and we'll go through this just as a
balance how does microbiological testing
differ from chemical testing right and
one of the most important um
aspects of microbiological testing is
you know
you're really testing uh things to a
lower limit of detection
you're also doing some quantification
but that's
also very dependent on the way that
those organisms are distributed inside
of that product
right the concept of lower limit of
detection or limited protection
originated in chemistry
but it's got to be carried over for
micro to understand how those how those
methods
relate to your final product and the
information that you're going to get
and again in cases where microorganisms
are extremely
low you know the ability to for the
method to detect
um is really determined as much by
you know the outcome of the test but
rather it's the probability that you're
even going to be able to get
your analyte there to test if you think
of homogeneity
in that sense if we discuss um
if we absolutely go and discuss like
heavy metals testing
which again you look at and you would
feel like if i take a sample it's going
to be
homogeneous throughout the lot or the
size of the sample i'm taking then you'd
understand kind of what i'm talking
about
along with some of the other
characteristics that may not just be
randomly distributed but we'll talk
we'll go through those a little bit more
we're going to talk about testing and
validation right
we're going to discuss the diversity of
sample types and the uses
like for for different tests i think
validations are extremely important but
that's due to the material handling
and the challenge of executing
multi-site studies to validate a test
and that's one of the hurdles that we
have right now with cannabis testing is
being able to look at
large scale um validations
where you can really look at like the
way that technicians are affecting
things
right things right and sometimes you'll
even be able to use a technique called
sample compositing
for both micro and chemistry and how's
that how does that affect
the the results that you see for your
validations
so if we think about it microbiological
testing itself though
uh the data is used to determine
acceptability of products in domestic
and international trade
okay but it's got to be reliable and
consistent amongst trading partners
and regulation and industry i need to
maximize the capacity and credibility of
laboratory testing
for both official and routine purposes
right and then
i think the biggest one of the bigger
symptoms that we see is the validation
verification
activities of proprietary methods of
time are going to be necessary
um you're going to have some fit for
purpose testing that will need to be
done
and we'll also see a level of complexity
uh that that right now is going to
outstrip probably where some of the
current um guidelines for validation are
and we'll need to know the legal
ramifications of that one of the very
last slides that i have
we'll talk about a technique for looking
at um
like for instance microflora that will
discuss that and then we'll go through
and unders try to understand how it fits
with everything else we're gonna we're
gonna discuss
so the essence of everything we're we're
gonna talk about is based on measurement
and so when we go through this we talk
about measurement itself
there's an evaluation process you go
through to make sure that your
measurement is reliable
um you know you're going to design a
study where
you know it's a and you're going to make
sure that the study is appropriate to
deliver the information that you need
you're going to choose a matrix to test
and as like i said as as
the uses for cannabis become more
complex those matrices become more
complex too
you're going to have to find methods at
times you're developing new but
sometimes you're comparing a new versus
an old method
to understand what that data is going to
mean
when we're going to go evaluate the
measurement process itself
sometimes you have to choose measurement
instruments and that can include human
beings
sensory evaluation is something that is
very reliant
on human beings as instruments and
they've got to be calibrated and tuned
to each other
just like anything else or any other
piece of equipment you might have
if possible you're going to need
reference materials and i think this is
one of the challenges
that we'll continue to run into in this
area whether it's chemical or
microbiological reference materials
and then you're going to have to be able
to perform a statistical analysis to be
able to say
yes what we're seeing um the measurement
process we have
actually gives us the answers that we
want and understand
what are the considerations though
whether it be microbiological or
chemical that we're talking about when
we when we do a measurement right
one of the things you want to make sure
of that the measurement you're picking
has units that reflect the variation
that you need to see to say whether or
not
things are good or bad something that
simple or to measure gradients right
um you want it to be consistent over
time you don't want to take a
measurement today come back three days
later
and the measurement system itself gives
you a different answer
uh you want it to be unbiased that
that's extremely important
and you you want to make sure that
you're characterizing product
relative to whatever the specification
limits are for that given product um
you want to make sure that the that the
measurement numbers you're using and the
considerations
reflect product that has not been
measured also
and that's the key right you take your
sample yeah i can measure what's here
but
my sampling plan and we'll talk about
that briefly a little bit later
needs to make sure that i'm taking
things that are represented of
everything i'm putting into commerce
um as opposed to just maybe what i have
sitting on my on my lab bench at the
time
but it needs to represent that
accurately
at some point the measurements you're
taking need to be useful in process
control
and again they need to be able to detect
the differences in product
so you can make decisions also you want
to make sure that technique comparisons
can be made
right and that means something as simple
as what if
what if uh you know someone has a
difference in the way they prep
a sample slightly difference uh slight
differences in sample prep can end up at
times making differences
in the way you end up getting a result
right and you want to make sure the
product information
from the measurement itself is
consistent
right okay so that's a duplicate slide
so let's go past that
sorry about that one sampling itself
right
and sampling to be honest with you is
the base this is the floor
of the of the quality system itself as
you go to measure it
and and i think i've you know throughout
my career i've gone through
and you know taught multiple sampling
classes had multiple discussions about
sampling itself
and this is one that creates a little
bit of a quagmire for people at times
and you see this both um and the
differences that you find in the way
things are sampled
anywhere from the food industry all the
way through the pharmaceutical industry
and what it's really based on is
pretty much the never-ending dilemma of
how much
or how many samples do i take versus
how much of the sample do i test and how
many tests do i run
and it absolutely dwells on the fact
that that's going to depend on
what you are measuring right
and let's just i i gave it three three
groups
where if you really want to look at the
characteristics to decide
how i'm going to sample and measure
these are good guidelines
we could do an all-day class on sampling
itself to understand the nuances of it
but i want to give you a high level to
think about as you go through and
develop plans for
uh different testing types and and and
if you were to refer
back to the first slide where it had the
um the tests and things that are being
done on cannabis
you know that were there from california
you think about them this way
one of them the first bullet point i
have here is you know is it qualitative
and homogeneous okay it's a yes or no
answer
and i expect everything i test to be
relatively the same
okay um an example of that is
um is is is the color green
or brown really simple to say
not gradients of it but you know i would
expect that whatever was grown
harvested and then as it moves through
to whatever being processes it
it's it's homogeneous you're gonna
expect that the same characteristics are
there
throughout the entire lot okay that's
one thing
is it quantitative and expected to be
homogeneous is the second character it's
characteristic group i want you to think
through
now quantitative meaning i'm going to
actually assign
a number for an attribute to this
measurement
right um moisture is a good example
right
where you know i have a gradient um i
can make it semi-quantitative but we can
talk about that at another time
but literally i have a specification i
want to know what's the moisture of this
product
we measure it but i expect that to be
homogeneous and represented throughout
the lot
of or the batch of samples that i've
taken and i also wanted to represent
the entire group now the next one
is where i think you come in uh to
to where the biggest difference is right
and and it's really the non-homogeneous
category this can either be qualitative
or
quantitative measurement and
non-homogeneity causes
problems and i think what you have to
understand is that's where sampling
plans have to vary
get larger get a little bit different to
be able to capture what may be
a low level of contamination in a very
large group of products
so i'll use something that we're all
familiar with for instance salmonella
testing
in a product could be exactly is a great
example of this
you would not expect salmonella to be
homogenous
throughout any lot of anything that you
made this is also true of the
aspergillus testing that you see
a lot of times where you're doing a
quantitative assessment but because it's
a biological contaminant the levels can
vary
inside of a lot that's why at times to
get what we call
a prevalence data or understand kind of
just the quality of the entire lot
you usually end up doing more samples in
those cases
how many that can be determined too but
that's just kind of
an overall general example of the way
you think about
those characteristics and how you take a
sample
and i think the more homogenous
something is you know again
the the the the biggest difference comes
in the amount
of samples that you take right it's not
how much
at that point it's like how many do i
need to take just to say okay i've got a
good assurance that
i'm not i don't have something crazy
going on inside this lot if i expect
homogeneity
um so the next the next thing i i really
want to talk about there though is like
you know what are the questions you put
in front of yourself when you're talking
about a sampling plan
and i you know how many samples do i
take these are common things i've heard
we work with clients now on exactly
these things how many samples do i take
right and then how many samples are
enough to verify a certain level of
quality
and then how big of a sample do i need
to take do i need to take
five pounds do i need to take 10 grams
you know anything in between um what
happens if this is different if i'm
doing indicator testing that comes up
again with for instance we're talking
about
uh the aspergillus testing and other
things like that that we're trying just
to get a feel is there something there
that would indicate there's another
issue
with the product that you you're gonna
need to go look at right
the biggest problem that becomes not
problem i'm going to say challenge
because i hate to use the term problem
but the challenge is the more data you
get how do you interpret it all
and how does it relate back to risk and
how does it relate back to the sampling
plan that you have created
i think that's really important the next
graphic
that that we're going to look at really
gives you an idea it's an overall
general graphic
of you know looking at a proportion
defective
versus something something as simple as
as the probability of accepting
something
that that has risk assigned to it right
um you look up one the upper right
corner where he says
producers risk which is the probability
that an acceptable lot has been rejected
you produced exactly what you want what
you needed to
there's a measurement error or something
else there's a chance that hey
everything was fine with this but it was
not accepted
flip side of that is the consumer or the
receiver's risk
becomes hey i've got a a probability of
except
accepting something that does have a
defect
right so there's a balance between those
when we do our sampling and our testing
to see exactly what we need and to
understand it
so let's keep rolling this is just a
simple graphic to talk about the
distribution of microorganisms inside of
a lot and why sampling is important
and again just think through this as far
as homogeneous distribution
and then the three examples of the
non-homogeneous and what that means if
i'm doing qualitative testing
quantitative testing and then what do i
need to do to
make sure i'm getting a reliable number
so let's move on to validation right we
talk about of methods and processes
just quickly the validation process
again you have measurement you have
evaluation
verification um a method validation is
all about reliability
you look at reproducibility which is
between lab
precision um you have repeatability
how many times do i do things in the
same lab and everything is okay
right you'll always want to understand
systematic error or bias which is the
deviation from a true value everything
has a value that's right
but you know we measure around things at
time
to make sure it's precise and there's
not a real error that
that prejudice is a result one way or
another
we don't want to understand specificity
right the ability to measure exactly
what's intended to be measured and then
the limit of reliable measurement
right what's the smallest increment that
we can measure with confidence
and then understand that there's
uncertainty in every result
this is a good example um and just goes
back and described work that's been done
by aoac and i think aoac and kind of the
way they've handled cannabis has been
they've done a good job of jumping on on
board and
trying to get some guidance for a method
but not going to read this but it just
tells you how they look at
for instance this is the example from
salmonella measuring
uh cannabis for salmonella where they
talk about the single lab evaluation and
the laboratory
um evaluation level and just what's the
minimum recommended performance
for that for that test
really quickly a single lab validation a
lot of times is one lab one matrix one
analyte
the matrix analytes is specific to the
method for instance and if you think of
again
uh something like heavy metals where
yeah there's more than one analyte but
usually those are done as a group
and the method can be done in one place
you know there's a lot of extreme
validity
sometimes it's difficult to reap uh some
of these can be
you know hard to reproduce in another
laboratory and they're seen as an
in-house method
this is why at least you get a baseline
for guidelines on how to do those it's a
good thing
intro laboratories again within a lab
and it's somewhat like a single lab
validation
typical statistical measurements are
there used to verify performance
again this is you measuring the process
but they normally cover
multiple matrices for one analyte okay
uh inter laboratory again this is
throughout a larger laboratory system
where you have multiple sites
complex measures of ruggedness both when
within
and between lab variation and i think as
we come
closer and closer to um uh
where you know where we're going to move
away probably from state laboratory
uh confinement or state you know federal
legalization
this is going to be something to think
about when you talk to someone about
laboratory performance per se
but doing these type of validations gets
more expensive they're much
larger proposition a little harder to do
testing itself right is something that
you know how do you determine it
and i think this is one of those things
that's always kind of interesting to me
like okay testing a lot of times in the
history of both
any industry that i've been you know any
industry i've been involved involved
with with both
microbiological and chemical testing
specification verification is normally
what drives it
right many of the tests that are done
aren't necessarily safety related
they're quality related
right and this can be uh you know
through through a lot of different
a lot of different procedures can be a
lot of different analytes
but normally you have an agreement
that's formed between a supplier and
purchaser
that often describe the test regimens
many instances those can be regulated
right and the regimens can include
physical chemical and microbiological
tests
methods oftentimes are described you
know in many different places where you
have crossover
fda at some point usda aoac io uh iso
etc um you have your state guidelines
for testing but again
they're described and you have to figure
out and determine how that's gonna fit
whatever specifications
needs to be met based on safety and
quality of the product
you look at potential frequency of
testing and it's determined by risk of
quality and and by
quality and safety again specifications
drive a lot of that it also could be
determined by a purchasing contract
that puts things in for quality itself
it can be determined by company policy
right and and to be honest um and
regulatory compliance is
always always always the floor
for what you work with but that again is
that that can also manda
mandate frequencies of of what needs to
be tested
and how often i put this slide in just
to show you kind of uh even from a
microbiological standpoint
to throw some things in of like how hard
testing can be the different things that
you might have to do
i'm not going to go into all of them
individually but you know
the microbiological testing and prep is
is difficult the chemical testing in
prep
is difficult but these are just some of
the things to think about
where you have factors that are going to
affect your final test result
and also the quality of the data that
you that you have at the end so
understanding how all of these steps can
potentially
um invalidate or validate a product
or invalidate or validate results is
extremely important
and you have to pay attention to just
some rapid detection technologies for
instance that are used right now
you know we're really familiar with a
lot of the chemical ones for heavy
metals other things like that
the the you know hplc glc
uh type type um you know instrumental
chemistry
the microbiological side you're going to
see biochemical we have color
colorometric impedance luminescence
fluorescence
um many different companies have have
things that they have
to you know test that have been approved
eliza's lateral flows genetic pcr which
is
one of the later slides i'll talk about
that just just briefly
because of because of the uses that you
start finding for whole genome
sequencing and microbiome work
and this is where we go into that where
this is what an article that i found
about you know cannabis microbiome
sequencing
um all the testing that's being done to
a point
uh especially on the microbiological
side but also you know the chemistry
side is really kind of solid with what's
what's there micro is being challenged
in
in every industry by the growth of whole
genome sequencing
and being able to sequence microbiomes
and understanding the
full potential and the groups of
organisms
that could be involved with uh cannabis
cannabis flowers
cannabis products as they move through
the through the um
through the process of ending up in a
consumer's hands
are really important and and microbiome
sequencing itself and using whole genome
sequencing techniques is going to be the
next area where you're estimating
you know and qpcr are going to be the
next area is going to
actually drive i'm testing for people
it's going to be important to understand
how these methods are validated
but this is the data that's also going
to be extremely complex
and doing the informatics and
understanding what it means to you
as a grower a producer
as a user as as anybody who's going to
take
byproducts and have those used and what
it means for safety and quality is going
to be important
this adds a level of complexity but it
also adds
an immense amount of information and i
think as time goes on it's going to be
beneficial to everyone
who's going to who's going to be
involved with um
you know the the biological side of this
industry even to the point of looking at
ai and other things like that
where you can actually verify um strain
types and things like that but
i think pcr and the whole genome
sequencing
is kind of the marriage of the chemistry
and the microbiology
is gonna help a lot with again
understanding
quality safety and other things that go
along with
um you know the the the measurements
that we use
for for cannabis you know thc
measurements i think are pretty locked
down
and i've seen methods there that are
really good but this is going to be a
really dynamic area here
that that i think we're going to have to
watch and understand how it relates
to everything we do
so you know in summary um i want to go
through just quickly and say you know
as we talk about methods one of the
things that we run into is that
they've got to be chosen to deliver
the most reliable relevant and
cost-effective information
about a process into a process
we have to have rigorous but relatively
simple statistically valid protocols
that can be developed and run
micro and chemistry right
reproducibility on the chemistry side
um the understanding extraction methods
understanding the things that
that that affect the
uh the outcome of an analysis or
extremely important
and i can't stress enough what it means
to actually you know have a hand in
those and
to make sure that you're getting the
best results possible
um economic factors are definitely going
to have to be evaluated along with the
technical merit right greatest method in
the world
but it's it's cost prohibitive um is
is tough to implement and use even even
if it's
you know the best thing for the industry
validation verifications will always be
a key part of the testing process
and then quality systems are i think
where a lot of the development
are going to come in place uh if if
we're going to end up understanding
um how what what's the quality
of the product that's being delivered
whether it's something that's being used
for you know to be to be you know take
ingested from the plant form
all the way through edible product and
anything in between
bottom line to all of this though is no
matter how much we test or what we do
there is no perfect method and we'll
continue to improve these methods
work hard at finding new ones that are
going to give us more information
and understand the challenges that come
with validation
of different items and and different um
matrices and and making sure that
whoever's using these products
has a safe enjoyable experience so with
that it's my last slide i'd like to say
thank you
um we can be contacted very easily at uh
website at www.mc2e.net
and my email is very simple mark
atmc2e.net if you ever want to contact
we're very happy to help anybody in this
industry understand more about these
topics
thank you